our veterans day is tomorrow but and
Founders coffee is honoring our vets all
month long though Ron when nikora with
Founders coffee is back with a special
menu and a special guest welcome back I
think of course so introduce us to our
lovely guest and how we're giving back
to our vets this month yeah absolutely
so of course our our giving drink every
month a new charity Fisher house this
month of course to support Veterans Day
and on our Founders coffee birthday
we're three years old in November oh so
we're celebrating two big things
now tell us you know what Fisher house
does and why and how this is going to
help well Fisher house is free and
temporary lodging for veteran families
we're on the same campus with the VA
Medical Center in North Las Vegas and so
we offer that free lodging for those
families to stay there why their
veterans receiving care wow so this will
benefit so many families so how are
what's the benefit how much money are we
are we hoping to give I mean as much as
the community supports us we support
back so a dollar from every drink of the
month will go to Fisher house across of
our location okay a dollar for every
drink of the month now what is this
special drink of the month because this
is what you guys are going to be going
out and getting birthday cupcake latte
oh you want to make it it's super simple
let's do it super simple you want to
make ice
whatever's the fastest okay okay poor
milk poor milk poor milk corn milk poor
milk for espresso this is like a
challenge oh I like this this whipped
cream on top because of course the
cupcake okay whipped cream okay
it's almost whipped cream okay
[Applause]
milk espresso cupcake syrup and of
course Funfetti sprinkles on top of the
whipped cream for that birthday cupcake
that looks fabulous now is there a straw
so I can actually taste because if I go
ahead and drink it out of that cup you
know okay I just I know it's good
because that's what you guys do at
Founders coffee what else can people get
if they come in and visit we have tea we
have lemonade we have toast we have
pastries You Name It We Do make all of
our food fresh so it is a smorgasbord of
coffee and food I love it that was good
that was good that was perfect you know
it's about coffee and community at
Founders yes and Beyond this opportunity
how can we help you at Fisher house well
it's just awareness so many veterans
were finding they don't know that we
have a Fisher house right there are 93
Across the Nation now we were house
number 69 nine okay and so I just want
the veteran family to know that we're
here to help them thank you so much for
all the work you guys head to head to
Fish House
of Founders and give back to our best